do you feel like you've done
all that you want to do
as far as being on screen are there
still things left
that you want to do cause you you
definitely checked a lot of boxes i mean
and i checked a lot of boxes you've
shown your range you've shown that
you know tp is is not just a one-node
attribute i'm not so edgy after all i
don't know tp has levels well i am edgy
but not in my work levels on levels
cleaning up yeah
listen to him don't listen to me you're
absolutely levels on levels uh and i
mean look at this thank you kevin i
really appreciate that well i'm not just
saying it to say it i'm saying it
because i mean it another question how
do you feel about your oscar nomination
for benjamin button i mean when that hit
that's a different ballgame that throws
you in a different stratosphere
my nomination meant i guess people were
paying attention um
i'm like okay they know who i am
[Music]
in that category with the other
actresses that were in it i mean i was
just i was just so happy that me and
viola was dominated together i felt i
didn't it just felt good that's massive
it felt good for me because i'm always
thinking about the younger generation
the imagery of that
because i grew up
we always know one
you know one of us it's very true and it
might be just one a woman and it might
be just a man you know so
just the imagery of two that to me i was
so proud that's dope as hell yeah you're
you're now a advocate for mental health
what does that mean when you say you're
an advocate like what are you what are
you doing what do you okay so i have a
um mental health organization that i
started called the boris lawrence henson
foundation and it's named after my
father who was a vietnam vet who
suffered from ptsd and also manic
depression
uh
bipolar
i started the foundation because when i
was looking for a therapist
for myself and my son it was hard
call my best friend who runs my
foundation tracy jenkins oh you never
you know you never made that donation
but we'll get back to that so anyway um
when i'm on your show and i do
everything you ask me to do let's go
i'll get back to that so anyway so i did
the foundation and i remember calling
you i was in chicago and i said hey are
you going to get yourself yeah
wait a minute
this is how i added it and then i got
ahead of time how much did i say i was
going to give it to you a hundred
thousand
why would you ask you better be glad i
say a million cause i know you got it
taraji whatever you need from me a
million no no
no no
a back pedal didn't to eat whatever you
need a million no okay 100 000. i will
give you a hundred thousand did you hear
this i'm saying it on the show i can't
go back i made you double it because at
first you said 50 but i can't go back
you have a hundred thousand dollars for
me it's for a good cause i'm telling you
you have a hundred thousand dollars i'm
dead serious but so i started it because
i knew that
i was having an issue trying to find a
therapist i'm privileged i have money
imagine all the millions of people of
color don't they can't but not even
don't we don't talk about it like it's
frowned upon in our in our community and
our culture for some reason and i don't
i don't know why
uh but it's it's it's looked at as what
you
come on come on get your get your ass
out what you doing it's never
it's never truly supported from the jump
it's never supported from the beginning
of the curiosity it's deep for us
uh
you talking about over 400 years of
oppression so you're talking about
trauma that black people have learned to
normalize okay we've been doing it for
over 400 years
normalizing trauma i just found out that
hush puppies
hush puppies
were actually used by runaway slaves to
keep the dogs off of them hush puppies
and we've normalized it
see these are things that we've
normalized so imagine all the other
things we've normalized
trying to be strong push through
the strength is invulnerability
the strength is in
saying
i'm not okay today
that's the strength the danger
is trying to push through the danger is
continuing to cope with all of this
compounded
trauma
that we have
ensued and continue to
endure we just got another hashtag i
mean
your kids aren't driving yet but kevin
when they do
you're the fear that you will feel every
time your child leaves a house
because they're not gonna know that
that's cabinet hearts
yeah so i'm not they're not protecting
they don't know what i'm saying yeah
it's real fear it's real you use
constant state of trauma you speak no
lies i mean
it's it's
it's insane to hear you speak the way
that you speak because it's
it's eye-opening to me look i can't say
it enough
i love you
[Music]
you